vous avez sans doute tous déjà entendu
cette phrase on ne naît pas femme on le
devient tiré du livre le deuxième sexe
de simone de beauvoir qui bannit tout
déterminisme dans l'identité sexuelle en
clair on différencie par là le sexe
biologique du genre si cette thèse est
tout à fait recevable pour le sexe
féminin elle est également valable pour
le sexe opposé
on ne naît pas homme on le devient pour
quitter l'enfance et devenir un homme
adulte et bien beaucoup de sociétés ont
mis en place que l'on appelle des rites
de passage ses rites étant souvent
spectaculaires ils sont devenues un
objet d'étude très prisé par les
anthropologues c'est arnold van gennep
qui le premier en 1909 utilisé
l'expression rite de passage
il remarqua qu'ils se structuraient
toujours de la même façon en trois temps
premier temps c'est une mise à l'écart
des individus concernés par le rite le
second temps c'est la cérémonie à
proprement parler et puis le dernier
troisième temps c'est la réintégration
qui marque l'obtention d'un nouveau
statut social mais plutôt que de vous
lister une multitude de rites mélangeant
les époques les populations il zones
géographiques
je me sens très uniquement sur les rites
des baruya de papouasie nouvelle guinée
donc rentrons en vif du sujet
comment devient tout un homme chez les
baruya pour répondre à cette question je
m'appuyais sur les travaux de
l'anthropologue maurice godelier qui a
passé sept années au côté des bars biya
à partir de 1966 concrètement chez les
baruya un homme est un homme avant tout
s'il sait se battre s'il est un guerrier
en clair il faut pas avoir peur tu es
les rides et les initiations sont des
étapes que les jeunes vont découvrir
petit à petit durant plusieurs années
en commençant vers l'âge de neuf ans en
les séparant du monde féminin c'est à
dire de celui de leur enfance en les
plaçant tout d'abord dans des maisons
particulières que l'on appelle des
maisons des hommes
ces rites parfois difficile leur
permettront d'acquérir un nouveau statut
social celui d'homme justement
mais qu'est ce qu'un rite arrive c'est
ce qui permet à la société de se
structurer de donner des rôles aux
individus par exemple concernant la
place de la femme et de l'homme chez les
baruya eh bien il faut comprendre que
c'est l'homme seul qui est considéré
comme un géniteur
c'est son sperme qui fait les foetus
dans cette organisation la femme n'est
pas génitrice elle n'est qu'un sac pas
moi qui le dit c'est le nom que porte
d'ailleurs son utérus guilia des
croyances bar où il a précisé que durant
la période de gestation
c'est le soleil qui complètent par ses
rayons le travail de l'homme dans le
ventre de la femme comme je le disais
avant les premières initiation commence
lorsque les garçons montrent n'a fait
dix ans ils sont tous séparés violemment
du monde féminin pendant plusieurs
semaines des hommes avec des branches
épineuses viennent chercher l'enfant et
le flagelle un garçon n'est jamais seul
durant son initiation il est toujours
accompagné d'un parent qui est un
adolescent encore vierge et qui suivra
également tous les rites
il ya beaucoup de cris beaucoup de
pleurs et ce qui peut passer pour la
perversité dans notre culture et pensée
comme essentiel pour faire accéder les
garçons auront tonnes et sans c'est la
première épreuve
plus tard vers 12-13 ans mais jusqu'à 15
ans ils peuvent commencer à porter des
flèches et sont habillées comme des
hommes c'est une étape importante
leur tenue était jusqu alors ouverte au
niveau des fesses pour appeler le statut
d'enfant qui sont généralement
entièrement nue cette unité partiel est
fait pour donner honte face aux petites
filles et pour les empêcher de rester
avec elle ici c'est l'habillement qui
matérialise le changement de statut les
vingt ans marque une rupture forte dans
la vie d'un jeune homme c'est à 20 ans
que sans en avoir le choix il quitte la
maison des hommes pour se marier avec
une femme qui n'a pas choisi non plus
l'amour n'a rien à voir avec le mariage
chaque homme a l'obligation de se marier
et d'avoir des enfants
car ce sont les enfants qui rendent
stable une famille a les sentiments
en début de vidéo je vous disais que
pour être un homme il faut être un
guerrier et pour cela se couper du monde
des femmes
eh bien il ya une seconde préoccupation
chez les baruya qui est vraiment au
fondement de la société
ce qu'il faut refaire les garçons c'est
à dire les ré enchanter sans les femmes
pour maurice godelier cela veut dire
qu'il faut réaffirmer l'idée encore une
fois que la femme n'est pas génitrice
mais alors comment refaire des garçons
sans les femmes à cette question
l'anthropologue aura attendu plusieurs
années la réponse que je vais tenter de
vous expliquer les enfants deviennent
des hommes par des pratiques
homosexuelles à l'intérieur des maisons
des hommes
les initiés de 20 ans qui sont les
parrains des plus petits si vous vous
souvenez bien n'ont jamais eu de
rapports sexuels
lorsque c'est interdit ils ont donc un
sperme pure et bien ce sperme il le
donne à voir au petit en ans éminent
cette substance purement masculine dans
le corps des enfants
ils refont les garçons sans les femmes
alors comment comprendre de telles
pratiques parce que c'est pas 50 nuance
degrés en papouasie nouvelle guinée pour
nous occidentaux leurs cours à notre
imagination est sans doute nécessaire et
donc vous pouvez essayer de comprendre
cela comme la construction d'un guerrier
supérieur aux fans qui a ainsi éliminé
de son corps masculins tout ce qu'il y à
deux féminin poursuivons l'explication
durant leur première vie de couple les
mariés suivent également des rites la
femme de faire une fellation à son mari
c'est un acte très important qui n'est
pas une simple expression de désir ou
d'érotisme
ça signifie qu' à partir de ce moment
l'homme pourra plus mettre son sexe dans
la bouche d'un enfant et donc ne pourra
plus participer aux pratiques de me
sexuelle expliqué avant est toujours
dans cette logique de faire de l'homme
un géniteur est bien le lait maternel
lui aussi doit être masculin et la
fellation permet de transformer le lait
maternel pour les bar billard le lait
maternel
c'est du sperme transformer ce n'est pas
la seule fois où le sperme sera partie
intégrante des rites avant le mariage
lon part dans la forêt auprès d'un arbre
sacré ce rite et sucrés et les femmes ne
sont pas censé le savoir mais elles le
savent très bien parce que dans un
village tout se sait c'est l'inconnu cet
arbre à une sève blanche qui ressemble
beaucoup au sperme l'homme initiée ce
poste devant l'arbre en miaulant le nom
de sa fiancée
puis il crie ce n'est plus ton père te
possède c'est moi à ce moment précis on
en droit se dire dac les hommes dominent
totalement les femmes et que les
premières sont des gros matches istres
si maurice godelier tester moins
longtemps sur place c'est sans doute
l'unique constat qui l'aurait fait mais
au fil des discussions avec les baruya
et notamment à propos des croyances sur
lesquelles reposent ces pratiques et
bien des explications plus nuancée ont
pu être proposées pour comprendre d'où
vient cette domination masculine
malgré tout ce qu'on a pu voir à travers
les rites les hommes occupent pourtant
une place secondaire par rapport aux
femmes dans les mythes
on raconte que les femmes étaient à
l'origine doté de pouvoirs d'arc et de
flûte sacré qui le rassure et une
suprématie sur les hommes elle était
également créatrice mais elle mettait le
désordre les hommes sont venus et ont
mis de l'ordre par des rites
ils ont créé les rites pour empêcher les
femmes de reprendre leur pouvoir par
peur ils dominent les femmes et beaucoup
d'hommes d'ailleurs dominent les femmes
parce qu'ils les crédits cette idée du
matriarcat originel et meetic se
retrouve dans beaucoup de sociétés
penser aux amazones chez les grecs par
exemple mais toutefois dans la réalité
ce sont bien les hommes qui ont le
pouvoir
au delà du mythe il faut comprendre les
rites de la façon suivante s'il n'ya pas
d'initiation il n'y a pas de mariage
s'il n'y a pas de mariage
il n'y a pas d'enfant et s'il ya pas
d'enfant bain le système est bouclée
donc les maires tiennent absolument à ce
que leurs enfants passent par ces rites
les garçons comme les filles d'ailleurs
donc c'est vraiment une forme
d'éducation collective donc les rites
sont indispensables au bon
fonctionnement de la société
c'est de l'ordre du politico religieux
depuis les années 60 les pratiques chez
les baruya se modifie notamment depuis
l'arrivée des missionnaires qui tentent
de bannir ces rites au profit du
christianisme dans toutes les sociétés
pape ou des changements se sont opérés
les jeunes gens sont partis travailler
en plantations il l arrivée des armes à
feu et de l'alcool
c'est bien qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
baruya sont en tête se conformer une
certaine idée de la modernité peut même
le disent être moderne c'est suivre
jésus et faire du business
et pour cela ils suivent le modèle
américain
à terme les rites décrit par maurice
godelier vont probablement disparaître
complètement et les occidentaux qui sont
opposés à la maltraitance des enfants
durant l'initiation s'en réjouissent
plus tôt en revanche les anthropologues
qui tente de démêler tout c'est pratique
pour comprendre un peu mieux tout ce qui
peut faire une société humaine ont
tendance à sans alerter
lorsqu'on étudie des cas où les valeurs
culturelles entre en conflit comme dans
ce que je viens de présenter ou dans des
sociétés qui pratiquent la scarification
l'excision et bien ça pose le problème
du positionnement de l'observateur lévi
strauss qui aimait comparer l'ethnologue
un astronome dresse un parallèle
débattue il dit quentin astronomes
observent une étoile qui meurt il n'est
pas triste
il observe ce serait valable selon lui
pour les sociétés et les individus
il faudra en sommes restés distancer et
neutre sans s'impliquer directement dans
le devenir de ce qui est avant tout un
objet d'étude
cet avis il est évidemment très contesté
en anthropologie
mais il met le doigt sur un problème
majeur jusqu'où doit-on respecter les
coutumes d'un peuple et à quel point
doit-on est préservée si tenté qu'il
faille les préserver
cet épisode est terminé je remercie
d'avoir regardé s'il vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à les consulter les
sources en barre d'infos j'ai mis des
conférences données par maurice godelier
qui vous retrace l'intégralité de son
terrain parce que là j'ai fait les choix
dans les rites que je vous ai présenté
j'ai pas pu tous vous présenter avant ce
kit et je remercie tout particulièrement
les types heures grâce à vous j'ai pu
investir dans de la lumière et dans un
nouvel objectif et sans redondance ça
n'aurait pas été possible donc vraiment
un grand merci et j'en profite pour tous
les autres pour vous rappeler que la
chaîne un conte hippie tipi c'est une
plateforme de financement participatif
où vous pouvez et bien aidé la chaîne à
se maintenir financièrement je vous
remercie et je vous dis à la prochaine
salut
[Musique]
mais